et bonjour david cormand je vous laisse
vous installer en direct bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec
je vous en prie et trompait un membre
d'europe écologie les verts en étant 100
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christelle
bertron du groupe la dépêche le cristal
rouge oriane bonjour david cormand au
jeune homme et david comment on va
commencer en parlant de ses opposants
aux mesures sanitaires qui se donnent
rendez vous samedi à paris son parti
hier de plusieurs villes de france un
peu sur le modèle des convois de la
liberté et qu'on a vu émerger au canada
est ce que c'est un mouvement qui vous
inquiète en tout cas la référence
canadienne louis m'inquiète parce que
c'est largement inspiré par
des mouvements complotistes inspiré de
deux cas ne sais pas si vous avez
entendu parler de ça mais c'est les
scellés wallace des mouvements un peu
foldingue ou un complotiste qui
soutenait trump et tout ça et donc je
vous aussi les personnalités qui
cherchent à dupliquer ce mouvement en
france comme monsieur philippot et
lespignan tout ça ne donne pas du tout
envie de soutenir donc non le mouvement
lui-même moi non seulement m'inquiète
mais
là après il ya la question de prendre en
compte l'inquiétude on sort de deux ans
de traumatisme pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes
c était des périodes difficiles
l'inquiétude avec des va et vient
parfois des étés comment dire des
dessins plus sur un peu autoritaire la
part de ce gouvernement peut-être
aurait-il pu être plus bienveillants
plus pédagogue plus plus ouverts par
rapport aux inquiétudes qui était
exprimé là on voit bien quand inquiétude
aujourd'hui comment on fait que ce
mouvement prenne d'un conte fait pour
éviter que ce mouvement prenne de
l'emploi à des bords en disant que des
choses ont été faites et que voilà on a
traversé cette épreuve ya encore
beaucoup de morts chaque jour mais des
vaccins ont été trouvés la solidarité
c'est fait j'ai eu des réponses y
compris au niveau européen et donc voir
aussi que voilà on n'a pas laissé les
gens seuls face à cette crise des choses
auraient pu être mieux il viendra un
moment où faudra faire le bilan des
choses qui ont été faites comment elles
ont été faites et pour viser une part de
responsabilité d'emmanuel la con dans ce
mouvement comme vous savez il a un côté
quand même parfois arrogant hautain pas
que sur ce dossier là qui peut exacerber
encore plus quand est ce que vous
craignez une gilet jaune isation du
mouvement cédant une cristallisation qui
irait au delà de la simple mobilisation
des roues très attention parce que la
tendance toujours à dire gilet jaune
isation c'est pas facile à dire
d'ailleurs
mais j'ai vu un de ses autres choses
pour moi c'était un véritable mouvement
social pour aller sur haut-fond le fait
que cette promesse intenable qui était
celle de votre autonomie est garantie
par votre automobile il y aura toujours
une énergie bon marché qui vous
permettra d'être libre et illusions de
la liberté a porté par la voiture ce qui
fait qu on a dit aux gens vous pouvez
vous éloignez de votre lieu de travail
vous pouvez aller en périurbain vous
pouvez c'est cette promesse est tombé
donc cette colère elle était légitime
elle soulevé pour moi d'aider tout ce
qui est des dépenses en présenter un
vrai
une vraie cause sociale là il ya une
frustration par rapport à une situation
sanitaire en agrégé justement des
colères qui dans les causes sont
toujours pas réglé aujourd'hui et ça
c'est le problème du mouvement de très
grande crispation elle brutalisation de
la société dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit bien qu'on
a une fin de cycle à la fois économique
sociale avec les crises
environnementales aussi les crises
écologiques il faut changer le modèle et
qui a pas de perspective est donc dans
cette danse manque de perspectives
politiques proposées emmanuel macron
c'est aussi le grand candidat du statu
quo c'est de cette fuite en avant de
continuer sur la même ligne ça crée des
tensions avec moi est ce que pour éviter
que ça se répondent il faudrait lever le
passé vaccinale qui est une des
revendications très très rapidement
alors là c'est un autre mais c'est une
des revendications des revendications
mais franchement je suis pas
scientifique donc mais j'ai toujours des
politiques ou d un filtre et décider
trait définitif sur ces sujets ce que
j'ai cru le comprendre c'est qu'il
serait levé un peu avant le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle
j'observe que ça tombe bien sauf que si
vraiment c'est plus politique que ça
n'était rien mais je note juste que ça
tombe bien frauduleux présidence tout
plat donc si on a ses marges de
manoeuvre là j'invite à le faire
peut-être un peu plus tôt si c'est
possible ne pas garder sous le coude
comment dire une date opportune pour
d'autres horizons que purement sanitaire
ça serait pas mal elle va parler du
nucléaire emmanuel ma couette à belfort
aujourd'hui justement pour défendre son
plan de relance du nucléaire selon les
échos il pourrait annoncer jusqu'à 14
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires au moment
où edf annonce que la production
d'électricité est au plus bas au que
dans le pays depuis 30 ans est ce que
finalement en lançant la filière
nucléaire emmanuel macron il ne répond
pas plus aux besoins du pays que vous
est-ce qu'il n'a pas compris à ce qui
n'est pas plus de sens de l'histoire ça
c'est toujours parce que quand vous
faites le descriptif que vous faites la
conclusion en tirer c'est plutôt
l'inversé sire que celui
du plan les effets d'autres chez relic
ose dire que là en l'occurrence on voit
qu'il ya un problème avec le parc
nucléaire français la réponse qu'apporte
emmanuel macron c'est la même réponse
que dans les années 70 si on va refaire
des centrales mais pas n'importe
lesquels puisque l'on parle des eps du
père fou comprendre ce que c'est ces
centrales dites de nouvelle génération
site orale est une technologie
assez ancien ça a été lancé à la fin des
années 90 les premiers plans les
constructions au milieu des années 2000
et ça s'appuie déjà sur une technologie
qui est celle des centrales actuelles
mais en plus gros ce qui pose des
problèmes d'ailleurs technologique cep
on les connaît puisque on a essayé d'en
construire en finlande qui a pris
énormément de retard et a coûté des
milliards à edf la dette d'edf c'est
plus de 40 milliards d'euros que tout le
monde se représente bien de quoi on
parle moi qui suis normand je connais
bien l'autre paire qu'on a voulu
construire à flamanville qui devait
coûter 3 milliards d'euros ce qui est
déjà une somme et qui devait tenir une
activité si je me trompe pas en 2012
nous sommes dix ans après on ne sait pas
quand est-ce qu'il sera mis en activité
même si le poids ce qui a des problèmes
de sécurité et nous en sommes d'après la
cour des comptes à 19 milliards d'euros
donc ce que nous annonce le président de
la république c'est de lancer la
construction de 14 réacteurs dont la
technologie ne fonctionne pas c'est
aussi simple que ça nous n'arrivons pas
à fabriquer ses repères c'était sûr
coûts colossaux et un autre élément
c'est pour répondre à la crise
climatique et la crise énergétique
on n'a pas le temps d'attendre 20 ans ou
30 ans or c'est le père c'est ça le
délai entre le moment où on dira il faut
les faire si aujourd'hui et le moment
ils se feront c'est une génération on
n'a pas le temps et naveen 35 maintenant
1 minimal 2035 minibar oui il faut
disait le père de flamanville se devait
de 2012 donc bon et la réponse sur le
climat c'est moins de dix ans et donc la
réponse au climat
c'est simple c'est
sobriété énergétique économies d'énergie
efficacité ils ont appelé à cesser
énergétique c'est ce que je tente en
garde à la sobriété énergétique c'est
cesser de penser que l'énergie illimité
et accessible et bon marché ce qui sert
concrètement pour les négligences a
concrètement c'est quoi les postes
aujourd'hui qui consomme de l'énergie
c'est le logement donc c'est tout dans
l'isolation des logements et des
bâtiments ça n'a pas suffi comme
économies d'énergie
c'est un tiers du stock car en fait sur
le gaz à effet de serre si vous faites
ça d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'à
l'allemagne arrive à sortir du nucléaire
et abc le charbon est la limite pour
qu'ils étaient très dépendants c'est
grâce aux renouvelables et surtout grâce
aux économies d'énergie c'est
déterminant après c'est sûr ça ne
concerne pas l'électricité quoique je
cours vers transformer parc automobile
thermique en parc automobile électrique
c'est un impact c'est en finir avec
uniquement le le comment dire le mythe
du déplacement individuel de voiture qui
fonctionne pas c'est des véhicules
électriques aujourd'hui caisse là c'est
les véhicules qui pèse une tonne 6 ou
d'automne tant qu'on pensera que c'est
logique le déplacer une personne qui
pèse en moyenne 60 70 kg dans un
véhicule qui pèse deux tonnes on s'en
sortira pas quel que soit le moyen de
produire tendre vers du zéro voiture
individuelle par exemple si c'est
possible c'est possible et quand c'est
pas possible pour les personnes qui
habitent à la campagne aux périodes là
où il n'y a pas
ça fait beaucoup de personnes et ceci
dit ça fait beaucoup de personnes dont
on a organisé la dépendance à la voiture
parce que on a déménagé le territoire on
a parlé d' aménagement là aussi vous dit
dites là on parle de moyen terme pour
les centrales date c'est pareil on va
pas du jour au lendemain à ces personnes
vous aurez des transports en commun il
faut ici de le faire quand même été
trouvé un plat de les solutions de
transport en commun ça peut être assez
vite ils comprennent du transport à la
demande etc etc et on peut faire des
véhicules moins lourd dire que moi pour
moi l'enjeu avant tout des véhicules
individuels s'est arrêté de faire des
suv pire que vous pouvez vous déplacer
autrement qu'en estimer si vous avez lu
pour vous transformer de vous
transporter en voiture donc là il ya un
enjeu il ya vraiment un enjeu d'urgence
écologique c'est ce qui est rare de plus
en plus il ya véhicule électrique donc
de plus en plus de besoins en
électricité donc c'est un peu sa pensée
sans mails non si on considère que
l'objectif des véhicules électriques
c'est de remplacer le parc actuel en
véhicule électrique ça ne marchera pas
pour des raisons d'électricité mais pour
des raisons aussi une matière première
pour fabriquer ces voitures parce qu'il
ya des métaux rares dedans qui sont plus
en concurrence avec tout ce qui est
numérique donc en fait ça marchera pas
en saura pas le faire donc l'idée c'est
de sortir de l'idée il y aura une
parenthèse dans l'histoire du monde où
on pouvait se déplacer tout seul encore
une fois dans un véhicule de deux tonnes
c'est physiquement pas tenable en quoi
c'est en fait c'est même pas une
question d'idéologie politique c'est une
question que c'est physiquement pas
possible par contre ce qui est politique
c'est de prendre en compte ce qui est
physiquement impossible tant pouvoir
l'anticiper je regarde moi excusez moi
mais sur le nucléaire ce que c'est une
question fondamentale donc emmanuel
macron va aller à belfort pour parler
devant ce qui était alstom ce qui était
passé à general electric j'aimerais
attirer l'attention là dessus celui qui
responsable de la vente de la dimension
de la divinité énergie d'un stop
ingénieur électrique c'est emmanuel
macron à l'époque il était ministre non
on va racheter très cher l'entité
nucléaire 940 me en or les turbines pour
fait de la technologie pour soi
nucléaire par contre qu'on récupère pas
c'était la technologie qui fait des
éoliennes penser que la france
aujourd'hui deuxième façade maritime du
monde n'a plus aucune entreprise qui
fabrique des éoliennes qui capable de
fabriquer des éoliennes à flot alors
qu'on avait on en avait avec un stop et
on en a mais même avec arrive à l'époque
qu'a vendu sur l'entité aussi aux
espagnols et acier mans c'est donc
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que la
france vient d'être pointés comme étant
le seul pays européen un retard sur le
renouvelable est pourquoi nous sommes en
retard parce que nous mettons tous nos
oeufs dans le même panier des nucléaire
qui est un panier percé qu'un train de
nous ruiner et donc là je suis très
inquiet d'un jeune président de la
république même plus jeune que moi a
lâché je suis très jeune quand même qui
se dit mon plan pour l'avenir c'est
faire comme pompidou dans les années 70
c'est une catastrophe écologique de mon
point de vue stratégique en matière
énergétique mais économique et
industriel c'est une impasse
industrielle si on n'est pas convaincu
sur les arguments anti nucléaire je peux
l'entendre c'est une impasse industrie
alors qu'on a les moyens de faire
autrement dit comment est ce qu'on fait
aller beaucoup plus loin dans le
renouvelable en voit aujourd'hui que les
éoliennes sont très contestée dans le
pays parce que ça abîme les paysages que
les panneaux photovoltaïques parfois il
faut raser des hectares de forêt pour
les pour les nausées faut pas faire ça
mais c'est pas ça c'est en chine qu'on
fait ça en france aussi on a moins bien
que dans le sud-ouest ya eu certains
certaines régions en gironde notamment
qui ont été blessées fou non l'intérêt
dur sur le photovoltaïque
l'intérêt du photovoltaïque c'est de le
mettre là où c'est déjà urbanisées
tirent sur des toits des maisons vers ce
qui se fait en allemagne toutes les
nouvelles constructions vous mettez une
et photovoltaïques sont quoi oui c'est
des surfaces qui sont déjà par
définition urbanisées imperméabilisées
qu'il faut optimiser si vous mettez du
photovoltaïque sur des espaces naturels
ou agricoles ou forestiers c'est une
folie saucats en gironde mille hectares
qui lui met les maghrébins je voulais
mais ça c'est pas de ça c'est pas écolo
ça c'est pas écolo c'est de la
spéculation ou défont des terres en
nature des espaces naturels et des
forêts pour faire du profit l'intérêt du
photovoltaïque c'est justement ne pas
faire comment dire des grosses unités de
production c'est pouvoir en faire de
façon décentralisée sur les toits par
exemple sur les toits des grandes
surfaces sur les toits des usines des
rôdeurs d'un ya plein d' espaces
disponibles pourraient du photovoltaïque
on n'a rien à voir avec ces ces projets
la wii est sûre sous les oliviers sur
l'éolien vous savez combien d'éoliennes
offshore aujourd'hui guide sur la trop
en france la une une seule regard des
autres certains disent que les projets
sont très ambitieux mais d'accord mais
vous pouvez pas dire aujourd'hui dans la
troupe
concept en france si quand y en a une
c'est déjà ou non c'est vrai qu'il va
falloir faire des éoliennes offshore ce
qui pose des problèmes écologiques faut
le dire mais quand même beaucoup moins
qu'un instrument aucun accident
industriel et surtout c'est moins cher
c'est moins cher c'est plus axé sur la
sur la limitation en fait de ces
énergies renouvelables oui mais ça vous
savez les étendre alors le problème au
jeu sublime et la fois être comment dire
transparent avec ça et compris quand on
est citoyen
si on veut de l'électricité il faut la
produire et donc si on veut la produire
faut aussi accepter qu'à des nuisances
il n'y a pas d'électricité mais n'y a
pas d'argent magique il n'y a pas
d'électricité magique non plus et donc
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt sain de
voir même qu'en tant que citoyen de
joueurs d'avoir la visibilité sur
l'impact qu'a la production vient gêner
l'intérêt de l'éolien malgré tout c'est
quand on aura plus besoin on sait c'est
réversible des déchets nucléaires c'est
quasiment irréversible ces 200 millions
de vies ces huit mille générations qui
vont nous succéder après on va parler de
la présidence pour ce long tunnel sur le
lieu d'une heure jb c'était important
d'en parler on va parler de la
présidentielle vous qui êtes député
européen vous avez sans doute écouté
avec attention à ce qu'a dit eric
zemmour hier soir sur bfm tv il a dit
que pour lutter contre l'immigration qui
voulaient construire un mur aux
frontières de l'union européenne et
soutenir financièrement les pays qui
étaient prêt on va dire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
d'abord c'est normal qu'ils vous me
posiez la question mais je suis un peu
attristé de devoir réagir aux propos
d'eric zemmour qui est
révisionnistes et négationnistes
guillemant sur l'histoire et qui
évidemment compte tenu de sa trace des
perspectives pour notre pays pour notre
continent qui sont dramatiques mais là
sur l'immigration ce que je trouve
intéressant mais sur l'immigration la
question et sa réponse oui mais c'est
pas neuf
il n'y a pas un problème aujourd'hui
d'immigration en europe je sais que les
gens qui nous écoutent vont dire comment
il peut dire ça c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
problème d'immigration en europe
aujourd'hui les questions d'immigration
liée au changement climatique est lié au
conflit c'est avant tout à 90% et
l'immigration à l'intérieur de pays déjà
en difficulté une part infime de
personnes essayent d'aller vers l'europe
et la plupart soit pour y passer par
exemple passer par la france pour aller
en grande bretagne et pour une part en
espérant revenir dans leur pays une fois
qu'il pourrait faire moi je crois que
d'un point de vue évidemment humaniste
humanitaire mais d'un point de vue aussi
très rationnel accueillir dignement ces
migrants y compris pour pouvoir leur
apprendre le français s'ils sont en
france voir quel métier ils avaient dans
leur pays pour voir continuer leur
formation et voir votre chien est ce
qu'on a les moyens de le faire mais on
n'a plus les moyens de faire ça que de
faire des murs fait faire des murs
d'abord ça d'abord c'est mal c'est au
niveau idéologique mais bon j'ai compris
que tout ça n'était plus important alors
que saleh rappelez vous quand même le
glissement idéologique il ya quatre ans
cinq ans que trump parler du mur entre
les etats-unis et le mexique tout le
monde disait mais qu'elle fout ça
n'arrivera jamais en union européenne
nous on est des gens civilisés vraiment
ces américains ces démarches au bond
cinq ans après on voit que en pologne ça
se faire et que j'ai pour le propose
d'envoyer la dérive des continents au
niveau des valeurs radiées épartement
accueillir dignement ça veut dire quoi
concrètement les loges ou comment
ça veut dire déjà bien avare et les
problèmes que ça a posé par exemple
parce qu'ils ne sont pas cuits parce
qu'en fait
on les accueille comment et berne a vu
les difficultés d'anne hidalgo pour
trouver des endroits pour les los ché
évidemment à ce que tu peux pas tous les
mêmes eaux au même endroit donc ça veut
dire avoir des lieux d'accueil qui soit
digne répartis sur les territoires c'est
à dire un accompagnement social tient
pas seulement leur donnèrent le genre
des personnes qui disent suivre ce
qu'ils ont vécu comme un traumatisme
enfin c'est des gens qui pour venir
jusque nombreux pays ont dû quitter
évidemment leur territoire ont vécu des
agressions avec des passeurs dix on a du
mal quoi financièrement déjà et oui la
même solution déjà ca que mettre un peu
d'argent pour le faire ça ne paraît pas
fou parce que sans coûtent aussi
beaucoup de ne rien faire pour moi je
suis alors je suis pas vraiment comment
il approche très pragmatique sur cette
question-là regarder au niveau
géopolitique les 4000 migrants qui ont
été instrumentalisés qui ont été mis en
biélorussie ce qui était un coup de dés
du 10 et du despote
biélorusse pour faire pression sur
l'union européenne et voulait ça soulève
la fragilité de notre continent on est
la première puissance économique du
monde nous sommes collectivement riche
ya des inégalités mais nous sommes
collectivement riche et avec 4000
migrants on a réussi à mettre en panique
cette première puissance économie que
mon cas je trouve ça tout bonnement
enfin absurde et donc pas vraiment il
faut désormais quand zemmour parle de ça
en fait son sujet c'est pas vraiment les
migrantes son sujet c'est de construire
un récit politique sur la peur c'est de
dire à nos compatriotes vous êtes
faibles vous êtes menacés remettez vous
en avoir qui sera vos protégés face à
ces menaces ça marche pour vous ça
marche en partie parce que ça percute ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure aux tout
débuts sur la marge de liberté enfin sur
la marge sur la le convoi de la liberté
ex est et restera sec les gens sont
perdus en termes de perspectives
politiques d'abord les paysages
politiques 1.222 d'exploser il est plus
très clair ils sont perdus en termes de
valeur et donc ils se raccrochent c'est
toujours pareil à l'extrême droite c'est
pas une réponse aux crises c'est un
symptôme des crises quand la société va
mal eux ils se réveillent ils sortent
peu comme les vampires de leurs de
chaleureuses
de leurs cercueils et tout d'un coup il
jaillit il attise les peurs et donc
zemmour sa
gauche et les écologistes aujourd'hui
vous avez raison on essaye de le faire
mais on est un peu à contre-courant ci
reconnaît dans cette espèce de clair
obscur où la parole un peu de d'espoir
en l'avenir de construire de changement
c'est quelque chose qui tétanise me
compatriotes et je comprends quand on va
déjà mal à voir des gens qui viennent
vous dire en plus il va falloir changer
ses engagements déjà on est en train de
perdre ce qu'on l'a on n'a pas envie de
changer on préfère s'en remettre comment
dire à des des références du passé parce
que c'est ça aussi l'extrême droite 1 c
ces nostalgies un peu fantasmée de
d'avant-hier ont dit on va revenir ça
veut dire qu'ils avaient du mal à
répondre aux réalités quotidiennes non
je pense qu on me répond je pense qu'on
a un jeu que je touche je pense que nous
répond soit assez précises au niveau
énergétique au niveau mais
en fait les angoisses l'emportent donc
en fait nous notre défi est double sert
non seulement de proposer notre
prochaine ça je pense que on arrive à le
faire mais aussi emporté une forme d'
enthousiasme et de confiance en l'avenir
c'est comme ça que vous expliquer le
niveau dans les sondages de yannick
jadot aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend les
français diront veut protéger
l'environnement on veut protéger la
planète et ondimba le candidat le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts et
la personne idoine pour faire ça or vous
dépassez pas les 10% aujourd'hui
alors d'abord ce que je viens de
répondre à des sondages je crois que je
les crois que quand ils sont beaux quand
ils sont pas moins je trouve qu'ils sont
la marque
du coup vous avez aucun aucun aucun je
crois aucun regret sans y en a un qui
était pas mal là se la jouent les
enfants et non mais blague à part a sans
doute tort est d'être second tour
aujourd'hui on verra mais sans doute
aujourd'hui la difficulté qu'on a c'est
exister dans un débat mais on vient d'en
parler et quand même cannibalisé par des
valeurs par un champ de bataille de la
dispute du débat politique autour des
questions d'extrême droite ça c'est un
premier choc non mais c'est que ça aussi
vous et cannibalisé par le fait qu'on
ait toujours pas réglé les problèmes
d'ego à gauche pendant alors ça voilà
j'allais venir c'est pas des problèmes
d'ego c'est la façon dont s'est
présentée c'est pas des problèmes d'ego
c'est des problèmes fins et des
questions idéologiques je pense
fondamentalement qu'on a une fin de
cycle politique à gauche avec la fin de
la social démocratie qui est un modèle
économique d'après moi obsolète
théoriquement et d'ailleurs qui se
décompose quand on parle de la division
à gauche on parle surtout de la
décomposition
la social démocratie et donc nous on est
écologiste c'est pas notre guerre rien à
voir avec les sociaux démocrates je suis
avant tout écologiste et on est happé
dans cette espèce de décomposition et
donc notre responsabilité politique et
c'est là qu'il faut qu'on soit meilleur
c'est de dire attendez nous on passe à
un autre cycle on n'est pas dans le
raccordement de la gauche notre objectif
pourquoi
s'en douter avec elle parce qu'on aurait
pas eu pour être tout à fait front ceci
dit une horrible a dû répondre à son
défunt non parce que je faut arrêter de
discuter avec elle c'est pas qu'il faut
arrêter de discuter avec elle c'est
quand je l ai pas fait recette
discussions et non parce que ça nous
ramène à des discussions de popol fin de
popol de tacticienne un accord possible
aujourd'hui avec rissient bien je crois
pas qu'il faille d'accord après ça
christiane taubira costaud berger
derrière inc et gedo peut-être fait ce
qu'elle veut moi je ne demande pas aux
gens de se ranger derrière nous et fait
ce qu'elle veut ce que je veux dire
c'est que la promesse de christiane
taubira et de la primaire populaire
c'était quoi c'est à dire on veut de
nouvelles idées au service d'une
candidature qui va rassembler on en est
où maintenant est-ce que ça a réussi oui
ou non on avis nous bat ainsi christiane
taubira candidate jusqu'au bout qu'elle
le fasse et s'il est fidèle à ce qu'elle
avait elle-même essayer de faire en
étant candidate de cette prime et en
gagnant cette primaire et en créant
dynamique ensuite on voit bien que ce
n'est pas le cas cela vous dit pas
d'accord avec christiane taubira moi je
suis pas sur les trucs je suis pas sûr
tout est d'accord par contre la primaire
populaire était censé faire de
l'écologie il me semble que yannick
jadot alors qu'il n'était même pas
candidat est arrivé deuxième si la
candidature de christiane taubira
fonctionne pas bon voilà la conclusion
aller vite
assez simple en fait chez vous êtes
cette réunion a créé pas mal d'émoi et
notamment de la part de sandrine
rousseau qui qui n'était pas contente de
cette que cette réunion soit fait sans
elle si j'ai bien compris ce que vous
avez un problème avec sandrine rousseau
jeune homme et ses ressources une
responsable politique sur twitter était
oui oui c'est son style s'exprime comme
ça moi j'ai une nature plus réservé je
pense mais ce qu'elle pense pas un
rapprochement entre saint-omer a
provoqué ce qu'elle est vraiment sur mac
je sais pas trop parce que des fois
c'est un peu changé en fonction des mots
mais c'est le truc c'est que je pense de
coûter globalement les choses
pour la campagne
je le pense parce qu'elles portent
un certain nombre de combats qui la
dépasse d'ailleurs qui existaient qu'ils
étaient prêts existants à sandrine
rousseau et donc c'est important c'est
une campagne ces différentes touches
c'est pas qu'une seule entité ces
différentes personnalités différents
styles y compris moi c'est déjà plus que
ce n'est pas tellement le mien je pars
du principe que quand on a des choses à
se dire il vaut mieux se les dire à soi
que les mettre sur twitter on voit un
beau mais c'est tout ça n'est pas très
grave aurait été merci merci beaucoup
des murs à moins d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin
[Musique]